well you know tier tier points i
remember in 2015 i i had this moment
i've been watching china basically for
that that was my focus for years right
and i'm watching the american media and
there's by the way that the media you
really prop state propaganda in china
right it's all sent kind of centralized
the talking points are spread out and it
just functions a certain way there's
certain patterns you watch it for a
while you see those patterns in 2015
i think
our media in america went crazy that's
what i saw like i just i said 2015 2015.
this was like basically post kind of
trump announcing his candidacy and this
sort of all these narratives starting to
build and these changes you actually put
your finger on it tim then these
changes in how the programming worked
right and i started watching i was like
wait a second this is like this is
working like the chinese media i'm not
talking about cnn specifically i'm
talking about broadly you know across
many media and this was the part that
was bizarre to me because over there
there's the xinhua you know propaganda
agency basically controlling everything
who's controlling everything here right
but somehow everybody knew what the what
the narratives were supposed to be it
was the weirdest thing and that's where
we suddenly you know at epoch times
became
weird and odd because we were just doing
something different right which was just
true being truth-seeking right so
something really changed in in 20 2015 i
think it seemed like they wanted hillary
and so bad into the office and then her
email scandal appeared and the media
just kind of this is like okay this is
an opportunity to break one of the
biggest stories of the 21st century this
is huge hillary clinton
10 000 plus emails of her working with
sidney blumenthal to get us into libya
like so much incriminating
and it was like silence because uh and
it was silence and it was like a
coordinated silence i i sensed it too i
just didn't realize i didn't see the
correlation between that and chinese
state propaganda what do you think it's
like the council on foreign relations is
related to coordinating like
att owns cnn so like at what point are
these corporations coming up to like a
group of like six dudes getting together
and being like i'm gonna have my media
organizations run this story on tuesday
like well we'll do it on wednesday well
they had something called the journal
list
so it's journal dash
list
and i was actually on some of these
things these were facebook communities
and email groups where all of the new
york media would be in an email chain
or a
like a forum
someone would post news they would all
see it and then everyone would write it
so this created this weird narrative
collusion i actually think people
underestimate how much this turned media
into
rage bait garbage nonsense and polled
the media class outside of america
so when you have people
who only get their news from each other
they're sitting in a room talking to
each other i'll tell you this
look at australia got a bunch of really
weird critters over there huh why they
have endemic species because of the
separation of land masses evolution took
a different path there versus another
place it's an easiest way the easiest
way to understand what happens to these
news organizations
you take a bunch of these journalists
separate them from regular mainstream
americans and put them in a room and
they will evolve their their perspective
and narrative dramatically away
from where regular americans are now all
of a sudden you get moderates voting for
donald trump who are like i think
america should have factories here i
agree with bernie sanders on you're not
not having the borders wide open and
then all of a sudden they're like that's
far right bernie sanders gets swept up
in the same thing it eventually starts
spreading it goes to social media and
then twitter creates they they take this
weird mutant
world view
from these newsrooms spread it out all
over twitter and now it's it's starting
to spread everywhere so i've actually
had this this conversation with peter
begosia and one of the guys who did the
so one of the people who did the
so-called squared hoax where they made
those they took mineconf and then turned
it into a feminist journal and then got
submitted and you know whatever
and his argument was all of this stuff
started in the colleges and i disagree
with that i believe it started in media
and social media i certainly believe a
lot of these ideas wokeness critical
racial and all stuff did start in
colleges but my argument is it was only
when social media and these new york
digital uh publishing firms blogs became
prominent that these ideas skyrocketed
in the lexisnexis database appearing in
the new york times and so when people
say yeah but the ideas originated in
universities i say a lot of ideas are in
universities but this is the only one
that expanded out of it so when you can
highlight a handful of academics with
crazy ideas well there's probably 3 000
more academics with crazy ideas that are
not cultural you know marxism or
whatever
but
when you get these people at big tech
firms we're on these journalist forums
who are using social media algorithms to
uh pump out as many keywords as possible
you get this warped broken cult and it's
expanding
and the crazy thing is
back in 2012 2013 when we started seeing
gamergate start so many people thought
these were just creepy weirdos
now we did a member segment the other
day about tulpas and mind alters
people who are have create they're
suffering from some kind of social
psychosis
so these are people who believe they
have multiple people in their heads
and they make tick-tock videos where
they're like one girl's like i am a doll
i forget to breathe and like these
really weird behaviors
they are it's a social contagion that's
emerging from this and we're watching it
happen in real time that's not out of
universities that's from what the media
is doing and and journalists are wrapped
up in it all the same so where you're
saying the chinese top down was it this
what you call the shinhwa xinhua
organization is coordinating the media
that you think that there's more of an
emergent phenomenon as well where like
people are saying hey that worked on on
cnn let's run it on fox hey that worked
on msnbc let's run it
although there might be a group of like
top-down oligarchs also doing it we
don't have any evidence that was my
conclusion well i think there's certain
opinion leaders okay definitely there's
jeff i mean you know there was a time
when you know basically the new york
times
set the the news agenda for the day and
everyone just looked at it in the new
york times i mean talk to anyone that
worked in those newsrooms they were
aware of the fact that that was their
job and that was their their their right
you know to to kind of do that right of
course that the the whole sort of
explosion of blogs and everything took
that away from them or at least to some
extent right
well so so um i have talked about this
quite a bit but i'll just make it quick
when you share an article with you know
kamala harris in the headline people who
are interested in kamala harris are fed
that through the algorithm if you have a
headline that says kamala harris jesse
smallette now you're getting both groups
group x and group y the justice millet
fans and the kamala fans and it becomes
exponential so what happened was in the
in the late 2000s early 2010s
these blogs uh mike.com is a great
example because they were pro ron paul
initially why well the ron paul love
revolution was very popular online but
what started working better was
anti-police brutality
racism and general wokeness so this is
back in 2010 or 11. they started
shifting from a libertarian internet
perspective into wokeness because when
you make a headline that says like trans
women of color fighting for black lives
matter against police brutality are the
strength against white supremacy or
whatever you have all of those keywords
crammed in that headline facebook feeds
it to way more people all of a sudden
now intersectionality started rising and
from that we end up now in a whole world
where our co we have members of congress
who are in this cult who believe things
that quite literally make no sense i
would argue those who control the
algorithms control the minds of the
people and i think that's very evident
with a lot of the agenda that has been
achieved through manipulation of the
perception of everyone's reality and you
could very easily shape that by showing
them certain events and denying them
other events talking about certain set
of facts denying other certain amount of
facts having these echo chambers that
constantly regurgitate the same amount
of news to people so they double down
triple down on their political positions
but i wanted to ask you uh yan
specifically there's a lot of people
talking about what's happening now in
reference to the cultural revolution in
china do you think that's a fair
accurate depiction and do you have any
examples of how that might be uh related
oh no absolutely and that's a fantastic
question i've had a number of people on
the show on american thought leaders
talking about this specifically
one woman named she van fleet so she
kind of became into prominence in
loudoun county she was one of those
parents that came up and spoke and said
i was actually part of the cultural
revolution i was there
right and and so she is actually really
thoughtful interview right because you
know because people will say well there
isn't you know mass killings or
something like that well that's that's
true
right but
the way that language was manipulated
right the way that uh the basically
there's the way the censorship works
there's there's a whole series of i
guess um
these the kind of cultural elements
right that aren't that don't have to do
with the actual compelling people to
behave a particular way everyone being
afraid if i don't join this at this this
sort of performance art this
performative behavior right you know
when i look at those looked at those
tweets earlier i whenever i see that
stuff i think you know these people are
basically virtue signaling to their
base so to speak yes i'm on board with
you that's really what it says it's not
really saying i i think this is true or
something like that and this is all very
much exactly from the cultural
revolution this is what shivan fleet
talked about and what about the
releasing of criminals was that
something that occurred in during the
communist takeover ah no so absolutely
so it's you know we have a we have a
series that it's actually very
interesting called the nine commentaries
on the communist party right and if this
was written by chine our chinese edition
for chinese millions of chinese have
read it it's a true history of communism
in china one of the chapters
i never there's a better translation but
originally it was kind of translated in
the first version i i saw as we were
editing it unleashing the scum of
society okay
and actually this is what people do in
the communist system they take the
people who have you know or cluster b
psychopaths all this kind of stuff and
you let them loose on society because
those are the you basically let them
do their thing and create the chaos
right and sort of break the system so
that you can recreate your utopia after
it's just part of the game and if you're
a capitalist or a landowner or a
business owner they literally put you in
the middle of the square start shaving
your head embarrassing you and try to
emasculate you and dehumanize you in
front of everyone one of the scariest
parallels when it comes to the cultural
revolution that i see now is the
centralization of power the
centralization of our economy and the
pure mismanagement of just the food
industry and the trade industry and i
think there's a lot of parallels right
now when it comes to the centralization
of that here in the united states
scientism and scientism like this idea
that there's the science here's the
perspective like science is not one
perspective it never was never will be
right but that's how it's playing out
here that's crazy right
the trope in our media is typically that
doing something for science was viewed
as like a negative
you know there'd be like a mad scientist
and he'd be experimenting on someone
like i must do this for science
and it was like a villainous response to
why they must carry it out it was
showing you to be inhuman now
you have people who come out and say the
science when they really mean the
establishment narrative because this
science has never settled it's the
weirdest thing for them to say that i
mean i'm sure you know
science is dr fauci tim please have a
correction for our tech overlords and
please forgive forgive us fauci is
science
i could not i could not believe that
interview by the way i just i i was like
i said it more than once yes yeah
he said he was the science twice
yeah he's not he's a guy and he gets
things wrong a lot but it's just so much
not any i mean you know my background
i'm an evolutionary biologist but that's
my background right like this
you can't say that that's just nothing
to do with science ever
right thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you